[Music]
well the ghost of george orwell
emerged from the grave today to
orchestrate a hearing on capitol hill
with the ceos of twitter facebook and
google they testified
at the capitol and at that hearing the
ceo of twitter
jack dorsey told us that actually
he believes in free speech it's one of
his main principles
i'd rather us focus on principles and
approaches to address these problems
i'll start with ours we believe in free
expression
we believe in free debate and
conversation to find the truth
at the same time we must balance out
with our desire to for our service not
to be used to sow confusion
division or destruction this makes the
freedom to moderate content critical to
us
and we believe the best way to face a
big new challenge is through narrowing
the problem to have the greatest impact
disinformation is a broad concept we
needed to focus our approach on where we
saw the greatest risk
if we hope to have any impact at all
jack dorsey ladies and gentlemen there
used to be some debate in the medical
community whether dropping a ton of acid
had permanent effects i think that
debate has now ended
but he did make a good point
disinformation is a broad concept yes it
is by design in fact it's a slippery
concept
used for political purposes and if you
use twitter you know that
if you watch the news you know that
remember jack dorsey is the guy
who literally shut down the sitting
president of the united states and
silenced him twitter censors
accounts all the time of people whose
politics they don't like they suspended
people for sharing the new york post
story on hunter biden's laptop right
before the election
obviously it's a risk when people are
reporting things that are bad for joe
biden's political career
and such as twitter facebook does this
facebook is one of those powerful
companies in the world
it affects politics in countries you've
never heard of and couldn't locate on a
map
and it does this because facebook and
most of these companies have found a way
to manipulate
human behavior through technology we're
not guessing at this it's not a
conspiracy theory
it's true in 2014 facebook conducted an
experiment that tested
influencing the emotions of hundreds of
thousands of its users
a man who helped invent facebook's like
button justin rosenstein admitted
that the tool he invented led to
political polarization and to teens
getting depressed
as you watch the suicide rate climb you
have to ask yourself is social media
implicated
in that of course it is facebook's
former director of monetization
tim kendall recently testified to
congress that facebook engineer
tried to make the platform as addictive
as cigarettes and of course it's
more addictive than cigarettes how do
people smoke versus how many people use
facebook which is worse for you
he also added that facebook's algorithms
help spread disinformation and division
and he fears because he's a thoughtful
man that facebook is pushing us toward
quote the brink of a civil war
mark zuckerberg isn't worried he wants
to know none of this is true it's not
his fault
don't believe the people used to work
there
any democratically agreed rules for the
internet
the reality is our country is deeply
divided right now some people say that
the problem is that social networks are
polarizing us but
that's not at all clear from the
evidence or research others claim that
algorithms feed us content that makes us
angry because it's good for business but
that's not accurate either
i believe that the division we see today
is primarily the result of a political
and media environment
that drives americans apart
it's pretty funny save that tape
remember the tapes from the 60s remember
the books that the tobacco companies had
commissioned were guys with a straight
face i'm a doctor and i'm telling you
cigarettes do not cause cancer
and then 20 years later all that tape
was revived all those lies
re-emerged when the tobacco ceos sat
before congress had to answer for them
well that tape will play the same role
in future hearings when we all admit
what's obvious which of course
social media is dividing us it's
destroying us
zuckerberg says he's got nothing to do
with it neither does
google's ceo sundar pashai
by far the worst of the three but at
least jack dorsey says
twitter does deserve some blame
i want to start by asking all three of
you um
if your platform bears some
responsibility for disseminating
disinformation
related to the election and the stop the
steel movement that led to the attack on
the capital just a yes or no answer
mr zuckerberg chairman i think our
responsibility is to build systems that
can help
you i just want to yes no answer okay
yes or no do you do you bear some
responsibility
for what happened congressman our
responsibility is to make sure that we
build effective systems
is not to answer the question uh mr
pachai yes or no
oh we always feel a deep sense of
responsibility but i think we worked
hard
uh this election effort was one of our
most substantive efforts is that a yes
or no
uh congressman it's a complex question
uh we
okay we'll move on uh mr dorsey
yes but you also have to take into
consideration a broader ecosystem
it's not just about the technology
platforms we use
now wait a second do we have news here
did ethereal buddhist techno god jack
dorsey just emerged from his psychedelic
haze to admit culpability for the
january 6th right at the capitol
no of course he didn't not in any real
sense he took no responsibility
and he'll pay no price unlike hundreds
of other people who were there that day
some of whom did nothing wrong
jack dorsey isn't going to jail he's not
going to be fined or charged with
sedition
an anonymous capitol hill cop isn't
going to shoot him
jack dorsey has admitted nothing what
he's done instead cleverly
smarter than he looks is created a
justification for
even more censorship on twitter
people who oppose the regime use my
platform that's what jack dorsey is
saying
it's okay to shut them up and he will
shut them up they all will you can be
certain of that
vince collins is a radio show host in
washington one of the smartest people in
that city and he joins us tonight
with his reaction to this hearing vince
thanks so much for joining us what'd you
think of this
well it's amazing to hear jack dorsey
say that twitter has culpability for the
events of january 6.
because i remember a scrappy media
startup called parlor
that was accused of that very thing and
it was banned subsequently from the
entire internet by the big tech
companies
amazon taking them off their servers
apple
and google both removing them from their
app stores meanwhile twitter will face
no consequence like this because they're
powerful and they're well connected
uh it's interesting watching these three
guys show up yet again it feels like
deja vu they keep
testifying before congress and yet
nothing happens it's almost as if it's
by design
it's like you know maybe if we just keep
calling them in and browbeating them the
public will think we're actually against
them
when in fact all of the people in that
hearing are basically on their side
they've been
taking their money for years the joe
biden administration stocked with all
sorts of
big tech executives who now have arrived
in washington and they're on the inside
advancing their interests as well
and you know it's interesting they're
talking about disinformation
disinformation is the pretext by which
they want to
censor and they have been censoring
american citizens this all started back
in
2016 mostly when donald trump surprised
the world by winning the election
and it was one of hillary clinton's 600
explanations for why she lost
one of them was big tech i can't believe
donald trump could communicate with his
base there
and as a result democrats have been
threatening to regulate these companies
for the last few years unless they
censor american citizens so where does
the censorship happen
where does the stopping of the
disinformation happen it's on the
powerless people it's on
independent media companies that's right
that's so smart
google is incompatible with democracy if
you're not for breaking up google you're
not protecting democracy it's that
simple i think and you're right they're
not this is potemkin
great to see vince colonies thank you
for that perspective
thanks tucker